what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like we are
not done with Bruce Banner AKA The Hulk
in fact it's looking like the She-Hulk
finale might be a lot more important
than we thought it would be and in a
different way than we thought it would
be as well originally we thought well
this might Connect into Captain America
4 new world order as far as the villain
is concerned for She-Hulk we don't
really know who the main villain is yes
we know that it's Intelligentsia but who
is behind intelligencia besides Todd
because we know that if he is really the
villain he's not the main villain we
assume that the leader is behind
intelligencia we assume that the leader
wants she hoax blood because the leader
is going to be the main villain in
Captain America New World Order and
given his involvement in Incredible Hulk
and what played out in that storyline
and how it's the exact same character
returning and yes the Incredible Hulk is
Canon to the MCU despite what some
people may say or want its Canon so it
would make sense that the leader would
want she-hulk's blood and it looks like
not only the She-Hulk series but Captain
America new world order as well are both
going to set up the world war Hulk
storyline because it looks like the
theme of Captain America 4 is going to
focus around super soldier serum and of
course the blood of the Hulk and now we
could probably assume the blood of
She-Hulk as well and assume that she's
going to be involved in some way shape
or form what the Insiders are saying
right now about Captain America New
World Order is that we are going to see
multiple versions of Hulks show up and
if this is true we're kind of starting
to see how World War Hulk could be set
up and it does look like it's going to
be pretty different from the comics
although it'll still have some aspects
of that storyline but that's what the
MCU does also keep in mind that right
now a lot in the MCU isn't really set up
for the planet Hulk storyline or the
world war Hulk storyline we don't have a
main Illuminati and we don't have the
main X-Men team or the Fantastic Four in
the MCU yet but She-Hulk did set up Hulk
returning to sakar and in the latest
promo we see that Hulk has returned from
sakhar and it looks like he's going to
be taking on the Abomination the final
promos for the She-Hulk finale which is
in a few days show us that the Hulk has
returned if you haven't seen it check it
out here
this is my show why don't we do things
our own way
She-Hulk smash
what is the responsibility of those with
power
those with the most power
have a duty to protect those without it
call my lawyer
I'm gonna whoop your ass my ass remains
unwoofed yeah let's fix that
Seahawk attorney at law original series
now streaming only on Disney Plus
now there's a few things to note about
this promo for the finale one is that it
says the unexpected Series has an
unbelievable finale and that's a pretty
big word for a series that some people
haven't really been enjoying that much
and whether you're enjoying the series
or not not a ton has really happened as
far as villains are concerned the past
three or four episodes we haven't really
been teased that much with a villain
we've got probably a collective two
minutes of footage for villains in the
past four episodes but obviously in the
finale it's all going to come to an end
the True Villain will be revealed and it
looks like that villain could be
Abomination because the Hulk is
returning and as we see in this footage
he is actually fighting Abomination and
this leaves us with a lot of questions
questions about the finale for She-Hulk
Captain America New World Order and of
course the new world war Hulk film now
the first big question that everybody
seems to be wondering is well is
abomination actually bad it's really
really looking that way from this promo
because remember a meal is not supposed
to be turning into the Abomination
however when Jen and the parole officer
went to visit a mill he apparently had
some type of malfunction with his
monitor on his ankle and we know that he
didn't really touch an electric fence to
mess it up we know he turned into the
Abomination and was simply covering it
up also something else that was super
sus is that one of the people from The
Wrecking Crew was at Emil's Resort and
yes everybody is talking about how they
were reformed and now they're not
villains anymore which was great but
that could have all been an act and it
could actually be that Abomination is
behind Intelligentsia and everything
that he had to do with Jennifer Walters
in court with his legal troubles was all
just a big Rue to secretly try and get
her blood and get back at her or perhaps
Abomination was actually trying to get
to the Hulk and he was trying to do that
through Jinn otherwise why would we see
Emil back in his Abomination form
fighting The Hulk and and after all the
Abomination is a huge Hulk villain and
perhaps they plan on keeping him that
way instead of making him a good guy now
at the end of the last episode of
She-Hulk it looked like Jennifer Walters
at the end could have been looking into
the camera at us breaking the fourth
wall or she could have been looking at
somebody that she was surprised to see
there if she was indeed looking at
somebody and was surprised to see this
person it could have been a meal this
would have shocked her because why would
he have been there and this is where it
could be revealed that he is kind of
leading intelligencia as far as twists
are concerned it would be a pretty
decent twist after showing us all that
Emile Blonsky has been trying to do to
turn his life around but perhaps they
were showing us all of that a lot
because eventually they would reveal
that he would be the villain and they
wanted it to be a bigger twist so what
does this mean for the finale well it
could be that Abomination could be
revealed to be the main villain however
going into Captain America 4 and again
given the connection between the
Abomination and the leader I would
assume that the leader is really in
charge chair of intelligencia so if
Abomination is the villain I'm assuming
they defeat him but at the end it is
revealed that there is something bigger
someone bigger that's truly in charge of
Intelligentsia that could lead us into
Captain America New World Order where
the leader is probably set out on
getting the Hulk's blood and they're
probably set out on establishing some
new super soldier serum it's said that
Marvel Studios is looking for actors
that could replace William Hurt to play
Thunderbolt Ross so it is possible that
the government is still trying to
develop some sort of a super soldier
serum and that could be where Captain
America Sam Wilson's Captain America
comes into play that was a pretty big
part of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier so continuing on with that in a
movie would make sense Captain America
has to stop an organization presumably
the Thunderbolts or at least the people
behind them from making super soldiers
again or even worse making Abominations
which could lead us into the next Hulk
movie storyline now again it's rumored
to be about World War a Hulk but it'll
definitely have to be different in some
ways from the comics now the Hulk just
went to sakar and he's going to return
so I'm hoping we get somewhat of a hint
as to what he was doing on sakhar now
maybe the movie that we get is only
about his time when he was on sakar
during these few weeks however I hope
that's not the case I hope it's about
the Hulk going up against other Hulks
and other hulk-like beings I hope
She-Hulk and Captain America 4 bring us
Red Hulk and Red She-Hulk even though
I'm doubting Betty Ross would return we
do have Titania who could go on to be a
Red She-Hulk but then you have
Abomination and possibly other creatures
as well that are introduced and who
knows what the Thunderbolts are going to
bring in it could be that world war Hulk
is really about the Hulk and other
hulk-like creatures going up against
each other and possibly getting close to
destroying the world hopefully we're
going to get a Hulk that is a true rage
Monster again that just goes absolutely
insane with anger and destroys
everything in his path and if he's going
up against other beings that are the
same ascent eventually that could cause
a lot of Destruction and that could
really be a World War Hulk however the
Hulk could still remain good now there's
also the fact that his son scar could
show up it's widely believed that he's
going back to sakar to visit his son and
for the most part in the comics at least
in the very beginning his son hates him
and wants to kill him so that could
definitely contribute to the battle as
well and with a huge battle like this of
course to the public eye the Hulk could
be viewed as a Monster again after all
we did have that line in She-Hulk where
Professor Hulk tells Jen once people see
you as a monster that never goes away
and this could actually come back in the
world war Hulk storyline him fighting
with a bunch of other monsters causing
catastrophic damage while people could
look at the Hulk like he's a Monster
again despite him having fought with the
Avengers many many times and saving
essentially the universe well half of it
at least there really are many different
routes that world war Hulk could go down
and Captain America new world order as
well as well as She-Hulk But ultimately
like I said not everything is in in
place for them to do a true World War
Hulk Planet Hulk storyline and since
Captain America 4 is rumored to have
other hulks in it and hulk-like beans
I'm assuming this is kind of the route
that we're going down with World War
Hulk but hey let me know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below and let me know do you think
Abomination is going to be the True
Villain of She-Hulk be sure to let me
know what you think don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe to
stay up to date on all things relating
to the MCU you can always follow me on
Twitter and Instagram for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
thank you